bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce premier
numéro du 7-8 politique de l'année 2016
et pour commencer l'année nous vous
proposons une édition spéciale en
partenariat avec radio sensations
une édition spéciale consacrée à
l'élargissement de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines nous verrons
ce qui va changer pour les habitants
nous verrons également les
développements envisagés mais aussi sur
le plan politique comment la majorité de
droite et l'opposition de gauche peuvent
cohabiter plusieurs invités ce soir
joséphine coleman berger maire les
républicains de plaisir première vice
présidente en charge de l'élaboration du
projet politique jean michel fourgous
merlet républicain d'elancourt deuxième
vice président en charge notamment du
développement économique et aussi en fin
d'émission à l'arrachage maire
communiste de la verrière l'une des plus
petites communes de ce nouvel ensemble
et je vous précise que nous avons
sollicités pour cette émission
la responsable socialiste du département
sandrine grand gambe également élu au
conseil municipal de trappes
mais elles ont indiqué ne pas être
disponibles une réponse trop tardive qui
ne nous a pas permis de solliciter
d'autres élus ps ce qui explique leur
absence en plateau ce soir mais vous les
entendrez malgré tout puisque nous les
avons rencontrés lors du conseil
d'installation de cette nouvelle
agglomération de 50 ans c'était samedi
dernier le 9 janvier
en plateau tout de même avec nous michel
logis maire divers droite de montigny le
bretonneux est élu président samedi
dernier de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
bonsoir bonsoir
alors saint quentin en yvelines
maintenant c'est douze communes allant
de coignières aux clayes-sous-bois en
passant par montigny elancourt
guyancourt ou encore mort pas un total
de 230 mille habitants deux cent trente
mille habitants qui peuvent se demander
ce qui va changer pour eux michel logis
concrètement pour l'instant cette
nouvelle agglomération n'importe pas de
grand chamboulement en tout cas pour
l'instant
alors pour l'instant non puisque
officiellement depuis le 1er janvier
nous se meut dans cette nouvelle
organisation
simplement aujourd'hui
vous savez que les compétences
s'applique petit à petit et de toute
façon je dire il ya des choses qui se
feront dans les semaines à venir
d'autres dans les mois à venir et la loi
prévoit aussi même sur plusieurs années
et un calendrier mais qui est déjà
défini il ya un calendrier qui est déjà
défini puisqu'il faut que de nous
prononcions avant le mois de juin sur
certaines compétences mais de toute
façon aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui va
changer pour les habitants pas grand
chose c'est la gestion qui va changer
mais vu le service sera rendu de la même
façon pour les habitants
regardez la première chose qui change au
1er janvier c'est la collecte des
ordures ménagères
donc c'est l'agglomération aujourd'hui
qui en a la responsabilité
on n'a pas mobilisé grand chance de tous
bords nous avons repris les contrats
qu'ils étaient aujourd'hui signé par
toutes les communes et c'est la
communauté d'agglomération qui
aujourd'hui en a la gestion mais rien ne
va changer les baies devant passer le
même jour le service sont rendus
exactement de la même façon
simplement pour les habitants ce qui
change vraiment mais janvier c'est que
nous sommes dans une intercommunalité à
taille humaine
alors que nous aurions plus de retrouver
dans une interview était à huit cent
mille habitants celle d'un cpu précocité
au projet du préfet de région dont du
gouvernement qu'on voulait nous imposer
et grâce finalement à tout ce qui a pu
se passer à l'engagement des politiques
de la région ile de france
nous avons pu obtenir que nous restions
sur un territoire à dimension humaine
sur un territoire qui soit vraiment sûr
vrai bassin de vie vous l'avez dit alors
la grande nouveauté de ce depuis le 1er
janvier c'est le ramassage des ordures
ménagères
il y à la taxe de ramassage des ordures
ménagères ça va être désormais la
l'agglomération qui va la prendre en
charge
comment avais être fixé quoi alors déjà
nous avons voté samedi le principe que
l'agglomération puisse se fixer une taxe
et ensuite ce sont les discussions que
nous allons avoir avec les différentes
villes pour que les choses soient
équilibrés c'est à dire du ja il faut
que pour les villes et qui ont payé un
peu plus que d'autres bien on puisse le
retrouver toute façon pour les peaux les
habitants il y aura une incidence aux
héros données sauf pour la ville et de
quads hier et qui jusqu'à présent de
payer plus de taxes
on va redonner les différentes
compétences obligatoires de
l'agglomération développement économie
l'aménagement du territoire politique de
la ville ordures ménagères c'est parce
qu'à plus qu'il ya de plus sexy à vendre
pour cette monnaie tous les cas c'est
une rihanna c'est la réalité qui existe
depuis le premier jour j'ai un des
premiers changements et pilleurs aussi
les compétences optionnelles la voirie
la gestion des équipements culturels
sportifs et puis des compétences
optionnelles comme le sport à la culture
est ce que cette agglomération version
2016 c'est une toute nouvelle
agglomération finalement parce que vous
avez aussi rendu votre mandat et vous
avez été réélus ont la part précisé mais
il ya eu une élection pour cette
nouvelle présidence de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines saint quentin
en yvelines et non plus communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
est ce que cette nouvelle agglomération
version 2016 fait table rase du passé
est ce qu'on oublie l'héritage de votre
précédent mandat et puis des mandats
précédents de la gauche aussi
alors on peut pas tout beau mais on peut
pas partir de zéro puisqu'il ya une
histoire les soirs réel les pistes vous
avez quand même aussi des services et
des réalités
il ya aussi la réussite la réussite de
50 on devine dès qu'on ne peut pas nier
il ya aussi la porte des nouvelles
villes est donc cet apport est quand
même important puisque on y passe on
vous l'avait dit 246 milles habitants de
130 mille habitants nous passons
aujourd'hui à 145 mille emplois sur le
territoire
nous allons nous avons désormais cette
gare sur notre territoire
et puis nous avons aussi les les plus
beaux fleurons économiques qui sont
situés sur notre territoire sur la
totalité de plaisir à coignières en
passant par trappe portbail l'encombrent
montils bretonneau voisins-le-bretonneux
guillon coup j'ai pas toutes les citer
parce que sinon si jeanne oublie une
après du risque de se faire taper sur
les doigts
en tout cas pas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que nous sommes dans une véritable
démarche positive et surtout nous
devenons aussi le premier paul ii
commercial des yvelines est un des tout
premiers en régions de france dont
regarder un peu tous les atouts que nous
avons sont parlé aussi des gros projets
que nous avons aussi affronter pour
l'emoa les années à venir on parlera de
ses différents projets au cours de cette
édition spéciale bien sûr votre volonté
c'est aussi comme vous l'avait dit lors
de votre discours d'installation samedi
passé de respecter l'autonomie
des communes écoutez à ce sujet
véronique côté millard mais rudy des
clayes-sous-bois une des nouvelles
communes de l'agglomération
on rentre dans une nouvelle
effectivement une nouvelle aventure avec
une intercommunalité qui a une existence
depuis plus de 40 ans et puis nous les
nouveau-nés donc avec un nouveau
fonctionnement qu'on va devoir apprendre
puisque mon père qu'on perd forcément
aussi une partie de notre de notre
liberté puisque maintenant les décisions
seront prises bien le pour les
compétences déléguées via le conseil
communautaire et donc tu le conseil
municipal
le principal changement c'est surtout
donc pour les communes qui arrive à
saint quentin en yvelines et qui vont
devoir abandonner du coup certaines de
leurs compétences
concrètement est-ce que des choses
aujourd'hui peuvent être apposés contre
la volonté des communes des villes alors
nous avons donc pas de mes transferts
c'est pas du tout la même chose
voilà on y est des moments dans un
travail collégial
ils vont en tout cas j'ai toujours pour
habitude de travailler de manière
collégiale
donc les décisions elle se prend donc on
semble alors c'est vrai que c'est comme
dans un mariage il faut savoir faire des
concessions
mais malgré tout la curation a le
pouvoir d'imposer si jamais certaines
communes sont réticents mais le pouvoir
d'imposer comme en n'imposant me pose
est comment le seul pouvoir que vous
avez c'est de le proposer en conseil
d'agglomération et d'avoir une activité
d'avoir une majorité simplement vous
savez très bien que tout le travail se
fait avant donc moi je compte vraiment
sur l'application de tous sur la bonne
volonté de pouvoir réussir et en sachant
que quand on se on se lance nouvelle
aventure bay à des concessions qui va
falloir faire des deux côtés aussi bien
pour les communes historique que pour
les communes en 30 mai
cg j'ai hâte que on gomme ces étiquettes
la voilà pour moi il ya douze villes
aujourd'hui qui composent 50 ans divine
et voyez que nous avons gardé le nom de
saint quentin qui est vraiment porteur
d'avenir sur ce territoire
certaines communes était plutôt
réticente pour intégrer une
agglomération l'agglomération de 50 ans
mais pas seulement tout simplement une
agglomération va écouter à présent les
maires de villepreux et de coignières ce
que je veux avant tout c est optimiste
malgré évidemment la pause la position
qui est la mienne depuis plusieurs
années une position très perplexe sur
les intercommunalités mais j'ai envie
vraiment d'être optimiste
aujourd'hui est de croire en l'avenir et
en l'exemplarité de cette nouvelle
structure
je pense tout simplement que ces
structures ont très rarement fait leurs
preuves
c'est souvent des coûts supplémentaires
alors qu'il faut absolument travailler
pour réduire les coûts et essayer de
trouver des marges de manoeuvre pour
tous est en tout cas et c'est le message
évidemment comme je dijon en charge du
budget bâtir un socle financier sain et
surtout très solide pour l'avenir
nous voulons nous intégrer dans ce
nouveau territoire
bien que nous soyons force et bien sûr
de l'intégrer au 1er janvier mais nous
vous devons nous voulons nous désirons
également conserver notre esprit village
parce que coignières c'est tout de même
un petit village lorsqu'on quitte la
nationale 10 nous arrivons dans notre
village nous avons un bien vivre nous
avons une zone un peu rural un peu
urbain effectivement mais nous sommes un
peu une commune rue robben et nous
voulons conserver ce bien vivre
également au sein de la au sein de notre
commune les nouvelles communes qui
intègre saint quentin en yvelines qui
veulent se montrer et plein d'espoir
plein d'optimisme
vous avez peut-être un mot pour les
rassurer aussi un petit peu plus
longtemps le maire de coignières qui
veut garder cet esprit village
écoutez où je crois il suffit de
regarder les communes l'historique de ce
canton
chacune a gardé son identité malgré
quarante deux ans plus de 42 ans
aujourd'hui d'intercommunalité et
regarder chaque ville a gardé ce drame
chaque ville est différente d'une autre
donc moi je suis tout à fait optimiste
pour que chaque ville puisse contribuer
à apporter sa pierre à l'édifice et vous
savez les deux mères qui viennent de
s'exprimer
ce sont aujourd'hui deux vice président
de l'intercommunalité pour vous voyez
bien que la volonté c'est que la porte
soit ouverte à tous et surtout que
chaque que chacun puisse s'impliquer
dans le projet de territoire que nous
avons est justement dans un instant les
maires de plaisir et d'elancourt qui
occupent les deux premiers postes de
vice-président à saint quentin en
yvelines vont nous rejoindre mais un
dernier point très rapide michel logis
et concret concernant nos repas et sa
piscine l'équipement existant est fermé
depuis de nombreux mois pour cause
d'insalubrité le maire souhaite bien
plus qu'une rénovation ils l'écoutent
j'annonce et est maintenant qu'on allait
reconstruire la piscine de maurepas
d'elancourt et de coignières parce
qu'elle est sur le territoire de
maurepas mais elles concernent plusieurs
villes en même temps et là aussi toute
l'intercommunalité son rôle à jouer
donc les discussions sont en cours
évidemment et je compte bien sur
l'agglomération pour participer à la
future piscine en tout cas du territoire
donc maintenant il ya une discussion
avec les trois ville et l'agglomération
pour que l'on fasse les choses ensemble
pour voir une nouvelle piscine à
l'horizon dans les trois quatre ans
michel laugier où en est le dossier de
la piscine de maurepas d'aussi qui va
forcément obligé l'agglomération un
vestiaire ensuite entretenir
l'équipement
je vais reprendre les propos du maire de
maurepas nous sommes en pleine
discussion et c'est pas le président qui
décide c'est pas le fait du prince dans
une intercommunalité
c'est vraiment l'implication de tous les
élus donc c'est une discussion que nous
avons entre élus de 50 cents divine pour
savoir quel sera notre positionnement
c'est le travail qui est fait
actuellement et les discussions quelles
sont-elles aujourd'hui des discussions
c'est est-ce que la clé cette
agglomération va accompagner ce que la
compétence sera plein pour l'ensemble
des piscines est ce que nous allons
aider financièrement une commune est ce
que nous allons essayer deux pieds des
regroupements qui soient organisées
toutes les questions aujourd'hui sont
posées nous n'avons pas la réponse nous
avons plusieurs hypothèses donc ça sera
à nous élus de saint quentin du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
a décidé de l'avenir des piscines et ce
sera vacciné camp j'espère le plus tôt
possible mais laissez nous le temps de
la réflexion
mais si nous le ton de l'analyse parce
que ce que le maire de maurepas déjà
fait une annonce il a dit il y aura une
nouvelle piscine de toute façon donc lui
il annonce dans son calendrier
le maire un petit peu la pression sur
l'agglomération de mettre la pression
sur la vénération sauf qui se met aussi
la pression sur lui puisque aujourd'hui
les vice-présidents de cette
agglomération
donc il devra aussi s'impliquer en tant
que vice-président de cette
agglomération
justement sur le sujet des piscines
juste pour finir sur les piscines
aujourd'hui comment ça fonctionne sur
les différents équipements de saint
quentin en yvelines
est-ce que l'agglomération finances
subventionne aujourd'hui il y a des
quelques piscines
sur toutes les communes de par contre
l'accès attaques dos mes rations
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la nouvelle
agglomération depuis le 1er janvier à
une piscine sous sa responsabilité c'est
la piscine qui appartenait avant à la
ccl op c'est à dire plaisir les clés
villepreux qui si la tuerie sur le
territoire de des clayes-sous-bois et
donc depuis le 1er janvier nous en avons
la responsabilité puisque c'est la loi
il va falloir uniformiser un petit peu
tout ça sera fait dans l'aisne pour les
sections mois prochaines semaines
exactement demande pas de faire ou
quelques heures ou en quelques jours un
travail qui va prendre beaucoup de temps
ont marqué une courte pause le temps
d'un micro trottoir nous sommes allez
vous vous demandez ce que vous pensiez
de l'idée de cette super
intercommunalités à 12 communes
c'est une idée moyenne je dirais c'est
mieux que ce qui était prévu à huit cent
mille habitants je pense qu'on n'a pas
intérêt à faire de trop gros ensemble et
que aller jusqu'au plateau de sacrée
avec huit cent mille habitants c'était
un petit peu fou mais c'était une idée
du préfet nos élus ont eu raison de
ramener à quelque chose de plus
raisonnable
non mais c'est bien c'est je pense que
ça peut être une bonne idée d'agrandir
si ça permet des structures enfin des
tas de choses qui sont nécessaires
est-ce que ça va nous ramener moins
d'impôts ça m'étonnerait je pense pas
pour moi ça va rien et ben l'union fait
la force
voilà et l'oignon fait la soupe c'est
bien connu non mais je trouve si tu pue
au nez plus on est fort plus on est
grand moins il y aura de gâchis et plus
d'efforts seront regroupés jeudi réf l
émission spéciale l'élargissement de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines se poursuit sur tv fil 78 radio
sensations en plateau à présent face à
michel laugier joséphine coleman berger
bonsoir vous êtes de la mer les
républicains de plaisir première
vice-présidente de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et jean michel
fourgous bonsoir vers l'est républicain
ed d'elancourt deuxième vice président
de saint quentin on va se pencher à
présent sur la priorité de cette
nouvelle agglomération c'est l'économie
seize mille entreprises 145 mille
emplois 17 mille étudiants
que fait-on aujourd'hui avec ce vivier
je vous pose la question puisque vous
avez en charge cette délégation de
développement économique
amy ont mis un accélérateur contenu que
c'est la première attente de tous les
français aujourd'hui
de saint-quentin bien sûr c'est de créer
de l'emploi marchand d emploi qui
rapportent de la richesse qu'ils payent
bien sûr notre modèle social
nos retraites donc bien sûr on a la
chance que nous le dit michel laugier
d'avoir de très belles entreprises donc
d'avoir une structure de pib comme on
dit donc très important de l'une des
plus importantes de france
on également un état d'esprit très
innovant puisque on était comme vous
savez classés dans les zones les plus
innovantes au monde dans les zones les
plus innovantes
donc on a toutes les composantes bien
sûr pour donner un coup d'accélérateur
alors bien sûr il ya aussi le projet de
pour nos jeunes d'avoir la meilleure
formation au monde une des meilleures
formations monde bien sûr et il s'agit
de rassembler les meilleures grandes
écoles que nous avons sur ce territoire
dgt hec polytechnique supelec king
destin car de faire la grande université
avec 70 mille étudiants bien sûr qu'ils
pourraient rentrer dans le fameux top 20
pas tout de suite le taux de 17,2 et un
jours déjà le top 20 de ce classement de
shanghaï et dont est donc ça nous
permettra d'attirer les meilleurs
talents les meilleurs chercheurs parce
que les meilleurs chercheurs viennent
dans les grandes universités pendant des
petites où il s'agit de changer un peu
le logiciel là dessus et de donner un
grand coup de booster et d'accélérer
bien sur l'attractivité des meilleurs
dans ce dans cette structure est de rome
de produire les meilleurs services les
meilleurs les meilleurs produits
c'est déjà le cas mais il s'agit bien
sûr d'accélérer tout ces derniers jours
j'ai pas préciser aussi dans votre
mandat puisque vous parlez de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
est une des nouvelles compétences de
votre vice présidence qui ne figurait
pas qu'ils ne figuraient pas auparavant
sous l'ancien saint quentin en yvelines
joséphine coleman ce berger la ville de
plaisir va apporter beaucoup aussi
apporte beaucoup en terme d'économie en
termes d'emploi en termes d'entreprise
c'est un point particulièrement
important aussi pour développer
développer votre commune tout simplement
développer la commune en tant que tel
pas forcément je veux dire si surtout
rapporté à l'intercommunalité vous êtes
dans une logique d aujourd'hui je vais
non non c'est pas ça c'est que je crois
que il faut il faut savoir réfléchir de
deux façons
à cette proximité dont michel parlais
tout à l'heure effectivement qui doit
rester là et vigilante mais il ya aussi
cet apport que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure qui est un apport effectivement
important des différentes communes qui
intègre cette intercommunalité va
falloir réfléchir justement sur la
globalité c'est important jean michel
fourgous est-ce que vous avez ciblé
aujourd'hui des choses qui marchent ou
qui ne marche pas enfin qui ne marche
pas principalement à saint quentin en
yvelines et qu'il faudrait changer très
rapidement on pense au projet de la
maison de l'entreprise par exemple qui
va fusionner avec la maison de l'emploi
oui il y avait un peu à un mille
feuilles
nous on a plutôt tendance à simplifier
le millefeuille parce que c'est de vivre
dans ce public c'est le sait les impôts
et l'imposteur une forme de privation de
droit de jouissance bien sûr d'un
français donc s'agit de blessures de
douala de limiter sa donc de simplifier
les procédures d'autant plus que les
entreprises sont demandeurs ils veulent
des choses simples pour bien fonctionner
voilà donc il s'agit bien sûr de l'épi
de rajouter aussi il manque un
incubateur c'est pour quand on crée une
entreprise et plusieurs stades ya une
incubation wee cc moment vous allez
définir votre fête prototype
je souhaite le service ou d'industriels
voulait garder 20 mois ensuite vous la
voulez pas ça promo paul déjà qui est
une autre étape il ya une troisième
étape où il faudra leur trouver un
emplacement avec des bâtiments là donc
on en sait un peu plus professionnel
bien sûr et puis bien sûr d'avoir accès
facilement aux talents parce que la
qualité pour eux pour vous développer
faut se re trouver les talents très vite
et je retrouve les jeux de création de
riz savent pas trouver des talents
donc il faut s'y rendent et procédures
déconseille donc voyons on améliore tous
les services ont créé un centre de
services autour pour bien accompagner le
créateur d'entreprise de richesse
jusqu'au bout et puis pouvoir travailler
cacher ses pouvoirs a réussi à prendre
des jeunes dans les bonnes universités
que ces travaux là voilà un peu le
complément en tout cas qui est mis au
point en ce moment aujourd'hui ça marche
de manière hermétique saint quentin en
yvelines doit se développer quitte à
concurrencer les autres agglomérations
il y aura des échanges aussi avec les
autres agglomérations pascal autour de
saint quentin en yvelines et aussi
versailles grand parc et à le plaquer le
plateau de saclay aussi il y aura des
échanges qui seront offerts vous allez
vous enrichir les uns des autres
comment ça fonctionne écoutez je pense
que le sco n'est sur un territoire comme
le nôtre doit être ouvert aux autres et
donc bien sûr que nous tendons la main
aussi parce que regarder par exemple le
projet l'un des projets les plus
importants que nous allons avoir
gérer dans les prochaines années c'est
la ligne 18 du métro 18 mai du métro qui
va relier orly à la défense en passant
par le plateau de saclay dont sylvie
retour doit travailler avec les élus de
l'essonne on doit travailler avec les
élus de 25 ans parc puisque ça passe
aussi souhaité un grand pas et ça finit
aussi sur le territoire de versailles
grand parc du moins dans la partie
chinoise donc on doit travailler
ensemble on l'a fait il ya encore très
peu de temps regardez pour l'arrivée de
safran et de l'école des mines
eh bien nous avons travaillé avec le
conseil départemental ne faut pas aussi
oublier les autres structures
le conseil départemental et verse à
grands pas chaque que
intergouvernementale solabios ailleurs
tous les trois ans tous les trois tout à
fait énorme et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
pas oublier puis n'oublie pas aussi la
région de france aujourd'hui avec une
gouvernance nouvelle et je pense que là
aussi on a un travail à faire avec ces
grandes institutions en sachant que on
se retrouve à peu près tous dans la
blague même problématique
c'est à dire que nous allons devoir être
ambitieux mais avoir une approche
différente puisque nous n'aurons pas les
mêmes moyens
nous avons aujourd'hui des des
subventions va des subventions des
dotations de l'état qui sont en
diminution complète et donc il va
falloir là aussi être beaucoup plus
ingénieux dans les années à venir pour
faire face à toutes les demandes et
pouvoir adapter aussi notre outil qu'est
cette intercommunalité pour les besoins
des communes
un mot sur aujourd'hui peut-être par
rapport à ces entreprises dont on parle
est aujourd'hui concrètement il ya des
entreprises qui qui regardent saint
quentin en yvelines et qui se disent des
grands groupes qui se disent pourquoi
pas venir m'installer sur le territoire
de saint quentin ce que vous êtes
sollicités aujourd'hui écouter une
d'abord c'est à en dehors des potes
d'encombrement
le matin et le soir vous êtes à 30
minutes de plus belles capitales du
monde
c'est pas rien sans feu rouge en fait un
bond vous avez les yvelines c'est un
territoire très vert très beau a donc ça
fait quand même ses atouts et puis en
même temps vous avez à vous avez un
environnement d'abord de l'innovation
ici à une culture de l'innovation
innovation aujourd'hui rien de
saint-claude numérique
le numérique c'est là la plus grande
invention de l'homme c'est la plus
grande un morceau de démultiplication de
l'intelligence de l'homme dont on est on
est devant une transformation et c'est
vrai qu'ici on est tous tout
l'environnement les grosses boîtes fin
de rebus hoteles au mas carte postale
cette carte la plus élégante zélande et
je cherche comme ça vous avez des
sources et à vous donner envie d'y aller
parce que c'est de la stimulation ces
deux là entre tous ces acteurs il se
stimulent mama trouver de nouvelles
solutions donc c'est un c'est un terrain
comme on dit la phrase qu'on a reçu
c'était faire taire d'inexcusable terre
d'innovation voilà c'est bien le terme
que l'arbitrage était un peu long mais
s'est mis d'accord
bonjour je veux dire pour compléter les
propos de jean michel fourgous
effectivement nous sommes toujours un
territoire attractif et je veux dire aux
ne regardait tout simplement mercedes
français venus s'installer chez nous
alors que nous étions en concurrence
avec d'autres territoires l'estaca est
venu chez nous en étions en territoire
en concurrence avec d'autres territoires
il ya deux hôtels aujourd'hui qu'ils
sortent devant le vélodrome
nissan europe va s'installer chez nous
prochainement l'immeuble international
vient d'être racheté l'ancien immeuble
de l'insee vient d'être rachetée il ya
aujourd'hui plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de mètres carrés de bureaux qui
sont en gestation et pour lesquels les
promoteurs tape à notre porte donc moi
je suis tout à fait confiant sur
l'attractivité du territoire qui sera
renforcé d'ailleurs avec toute toute la
nouvelle partie de ce territoire puisque
d'art aussi de belles entreprises de
belles enseignes de surprise sur morte à
coignières son jeu d'hier au contraire
je pense que tout simplement de vous
dire comme je vous ai présenté tout à
l'air d'avoir un territoire aujourd'hui
avec cette gare il ya camille pas
beaucoup de territoires qui peuvent en
dire autant
on va se concentrer à présent sur
l'arrivée d'une commune de poids dans
l'agglomération c'est celle de plaisir
plaisir qui fait une entrée remarquée
dans saint quentin en yvelines puisque
vous récupérez la première ville
c'est dense et justement josefina
commons berger récupérer la première
vice-présidence c'est un signal positif
selon vous envoyer aux nouvelles
communes au delà de votre poids
démographique qui est important que si
vous êtes la deuxième commune en terme
d'habitants du nombre d'habitants est ce
que c'est un signal positif aussi envoyé
aux nouvelles communes bien sûr
évidemment c'est un signal positif
puisque les cinq communes entrantes ont
des attentes et ont effectivement aussi
quelques interrogations vous avez pu
entendre mes collègues l'évoquer c'est
quelque chose qui est quand même porté
par un optimisme et par une vraie
dynamique et donc ça il faut vraiment le
l'entendre c'est quelque chose qui est
fondamental ce que je voudrais dire par
rapport à cette vice-présidence première
vice-présidence qui était avant entre
les mains de jean michel et je le
remercie d'avoir accepté que voilà lié
ce geste fort vis-à-vis des cinq
communes en 30 puisque nous travaillons
ensemble pour entrer c'est ce projet de
territoire
j'ai demandé à michel laugier de m'en
donner la responsabilité parce qu'il me
semble fondamental qu'il puisse y avoir
au sein de cette intercommunalité un
véritable projet de territoire pour
avoir échangé avec les maires non
seulement les mets rentrant mais aussi
les maires historique
j'ai pu me rendre compte que c'était une
attente qui était véritablement souhaité
c'était quelque chose qui qui doit nous
donner une feuille de route précise pour
les années à venir
aujourd'hui moi j'ai pu entendre et puis
de maintenant on travaille depuis
quelques mois ensemble
j'ai pu entendre qu'il y a énormément de
choses qui se passent ici bien sûr et au
sein des cinq communes mais je crois
qu'il est important aujourd'hui qu'on
puisse regrouper justement l'existant en
faire je dirais peut-être une étude et
surtout développer cette feuille de
route important pour les années à venir
avec ambition et je pense qu'il va nous
falloir une année pour pouvoir mettre en
place ce projet de territoire que nous
présenterons dans quelques mois pour
pouvoir effectivement nous appuyer
là-dessus tant au niveau du
développement économique qui est
prioritaire est fondamental pour une
véritable vie au sein de cette
intercommunalité mais également pour
toutes les autres délégations qui sont
fondamentales pour une ville comme
plaisir réintégrer l'agglomération
trente ans après presque trente ans
après c'est quelque chose vous le dise
et de positif vous êtes dans une vraie
dynamique positive est-ce qu'il ya quand
même des motifs d'inquiétude aujourd'hui
ou alors 0 inquiétude à l'horizon on n'a
pas d'inquiétude
la confiance est totale parce que comme
disait michel le président aujourd'hui
on est dans une dans un échange on est
dans une discussion on est effectivement
dans un montage de projets en commun
on n'est pas ici pour subir ce qui se
faisait ou ce qui se fait sur
l'intercommunalité on est là pour créer
ensemble et d'ailleurs les mots comme tu
le disais michele tout cas l'heure des
entrants d historique
il va falloir véritablement les oubliés
je suis d'accord avec lui il faut
maintenant dire l'intercommunalité on en
fait partie
bien sûr il y aura des discussions bien
sûr il y aura des des interrogations et
peut-être même des frictions c'est tout
à fait légitime et normal mais en tout
cas moi j'ai pas d'inquiétude les
plaisirs on n'en n'ont pas on s'est
engagés les uns et les autres à ce
qu'est un équilibre effectivement du
mieux possible au niveau fiscal dans ma
délégation
vous avez pu constater j'ai aussi la
mutualisation des réseaux donc c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on va être très
vigilants pour que justement et bien
l'intercommunauté apporter un plus et
non pas 1 - donc pas blessé mais total
le poste précis vice présidente en
charge de l'élaboration du projet
politique de la mutualisation du conseil
des jeux préférés que vous rajoutiez
c'est le message officiel une erreur je
les signaler aux yeux c'est le projet de
territoire et non pas le projet
politique mais vous l'avez fait en
direct merci parlons un peu d'histoire
puisque vous êtes une femme de théâtre
vous avez mises en scène dans votre vie
professionnelle passée plusieurs pièces
la culture justement c'est un sujet un
peu polémique entre droite et gauche à
saint quentin en yvelines
l'opposition dénonce souvent la baisse
des subventions pour certaines salles
est ce que c'est un sujet auquel vous
serez particulièrement attentifs vous
est peut-être amené une voie différente
je serai à ton petit d'abord journée la
délégation au niveau 2
ma vice-présidence au niveau du
département donc j'y serai bien
évidemment attentif je sais que il n'y a
pas de bagarres de droite et de gauche
c'est pas une question de bagarre sur la
culture c'est plutôt une question de
gestion c'est plutôt une question de
rigueur hier qu'aujourd'hui que ce soit
au niveau départemental national et au
niveau de l'interco et des collectivités
nous avons des paires de dotation
tellement importante est tellement forte
que nous sommes obligés de prendre des
décisions skipper voilà et on est obligé
de faire des choix peut-être
qu'effectivement le projet de territoire
va nous permettre d'avoir une
orientation avec des accords avec les
communes qui vont nous permettre
d'accompagner au mieux le travail qui a
été fait au niveau culturel sur
l'ensemble de l'intercommunalité pour ne
pas dire que c'est un abandon parce que
c'est vraiment pas comme ça qu'il faut
le voir
et si vous me permettez rajouter
aujourd'hui dans ses difficultés
aujourd'hui de notre de notre société il
est important que la culture et sa place
on sera vigilants mais on sera aussi
rigoureux sur tout ce qui est gestion et
finances cette édition du 7 8 politiques
spéciales se poursuit et le retourne
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur le
plateau jean michel fourgous et
joséphine coleman ce berger et michel
auger vous restez encore en plateau un
petit peu va nous rejoindre à présent en
plateau à linge h et le maire communiste
de la verrière ce sera juste après ces
réactions d'élus de gauche étaient
samedi matin lors de l'installation de
cette agglomération et n'ont pas
apprécié être écarté de l'exécutif on va
y revenir écouter on n'a pas eu
aujourd'hui avec l'élection
du président est de onze vice-présidents
tous issus des villes de droite
on n'a pas eu ce qu'on appelle là par le
partage de la gouvernance
cela veut dire que quatre communes ont
été mises à l'écart
cela veut dire que 73 mille habitants
leur représentant légitimement élus sont
écartés de toute responsabilité ce n'est
vraiment pas un bon départ donc une
nouvelle fois puisque je l'avais déjà
fait j'en appelle à la raison j'appelle
les élus de cette majorité à la à la
raison républicaine
pour qu'on puisse travailler tous
ensemble et que derrière tout leur
toutes leurs idées partisanes
un sectarisme qu'on sent bien chez
certains mais que au delà de ça on
puisse se concentrer sur le coeur des
choses pour une coopération
intercommunale 40 ans de mandat j'ai
jamais vu organiser un travail comme ça
et c'est la seule communauté
d'agglomération où il ya ce principe
moi j'ai téléphoné partout et partout il
ya un partage des responsabilités ce qui
n'empêche pas qu'il ya une majorité on
va d'accord vous expliquer qu'on en soit
arrivé à cette situation ce matin c'est
le fruit de de ce qui s'est passé dans
les derniers mois en fait un et la
tension allait monter ces derniers mois
ça a été rappelé par
et
les différents intervenants dont à une
forme d' escalade dans l'incompréhension
et dans les tensions et dans le non
respect aussi c'est ça qu'il faut casser
maintenant pour passer à une autre
histoire et on espère que michel laugier
deuxième version sera plus ouvert que
michel laugier sur la fin de la dernière
mandature et jour précise si vous venez
de nous rejoindre que nous avons
sollicité la responsable socialiste que
vous venez d'entendre sandrine grand
gant pour venir en plateau également élu
au conseil municipal de trappes elle a
indiqué trop tardivement ne pas être
disponibles réponse trop tardive ce qui
ne nous a pas permis de solliciter les
autres élus socialistes ce qui explique
qu'ils ne sont pas présents ce soir sur
ce plateau à l'aja je vous êtes là vous
ce soir sur ce bateau bonsoir le maire
de la verrière vous êtes dans
l'opposition justement comment vous
réagissez aux fuites de ne pas avoir
l'opposition la gauche aujourd'hui de
vice présidence au sein de la de saint
quentin en yvelines
écoutez moi je retiens les propos de kim
celle de logis avait donné il ya
quelques mois c'était pas une opposition
c'est une minorité
donc nous sommes représentant de la
minorité et puis toujours le même
sentiment c'est que dans la gestion
d'une agglomération il ya bien sûr des
sensibilités politiques qui d'ailleurs
quelques fois vont bien au-delà de la
seule répartition droite gauche
il ya des sensibilités à droite et les
sensibilités à gauche de nature diverse
et donc une agglomération doit pouvoir
se gérer non pas en passant outre ses
différences et ses sensibilités
mais en les intégrant dans le débat et
dans le dialogue pour avoir un projet
territoire qui correspondent aux besoins
de nos habitants dans le respect de nos
diversités la nouvelle agglomération
onze vice-présidents cinq conseillers
communautaires aucun élu de gauche
on l'a bien compris pourquoi ce choix
très clairement non donc du côté du
gauche c'est faux puisque il sort quand
même présente dans le bureau sélection
au sein du bureau mais je ne sois une
vice-présidence de mettre d'accord mais
attendez il ya le problème de la de la
gestion revenir d'une agglomération il
ya le problème de la participation des
élus et surtout la participation des
communes et à ce jour moi j'ai fait en
sorte que toutes les communes puissent
est présente dans toutes les instances
de décision
donc on peut pas dire que la gauche et
est soit écartée parce que c'est faux
aucune délibération de pourra se prendre
sans la présence au desus gauche on est
arrivé à une situation effectivement
mais une situation qui a été aussi
provoqué par des postures qui ont eu
lieu parce que j'ai entendu des
sanctions les élus gossip j'ai entendu
ça ils n'ont pas été peut-être assez
conciliant sur les yeux fendus pas du
tout ce que c'est pas du tout ce que je
dis laissez moi l'expression pas le
reportage de prévention non mais sur le
banc écoutez je pense que tout le monde
me connaît assez bien pour pour savoir
que je me suis pas sectaire loin de là
mais par contre il ya des comportements
aussi quand tu dois avoir des
responsabilités
il faut aussi être à la hauteur et quand
on a passé des mois à voir tout
simplement des manifestants très
souriante et très politisée qui sont
venus devant le conseil d'agglomération
le sco n'a des sciences se dépenser
l'argent qu'ils étaient en grève
je parle pas d argent qui sont en grève
je parle des personnes qui étaient
venues manifester lors de décisions que
nous devions prendre à l'occasion de
budget qui est tout à fait difficile à
mettre en place compte tenu du
désengagement de l'état dont vous tout
le monde sait de quoi je veux parler
la deuxième chose aussi c'est que moi je
ne peux pas accepter que healy et la
politique de la chaise vide j'ai aussi
siégé dans la minorité s'est toujours
senti dans là dedans la minorité et j'ai
toujours respecté la place je suis
toujours venu à toutes les réunions même
s'il n'était pas d'accord
voilà à torpiller il ya aussi un
comportement les mots sont très facile
devant une caméra c'est très facile
prendre à partie les journalistes c'est
très facile et simplement après il ya
aussi des actes et je crois que moi je
suis plus sur les actes donc j'aurais
préféré que les élus qui aujourd'hui se
plaignent soit à la hauteur lorsque je
leur ai tendu la main
simplement on a focalisé sur beaucoup de
choses notamment sur la représentation à
75 représentant 75 euros présentant on a
focalisé en plus sur une personne et en
me disant mais lola nous là vous avez la
majorité qualifiée je leur ai prouvé que
non donc on a focalisé là dessus on a
oublié la gouvernance les dispositions
n'a pas répondu à mes propositions
je trouve que c'est un petit peu dommage
mais cherchez l'erreur en tout cas moi
j'avais tout fait pour quelque chose se
passe bien mais on temps faut-il après
avoir une posture qui convient et qu'on
soit à la hauteur
le mot de la fin sur cette séquence ce
sera pour alexandra rosetti mary des
voisins le bretonneux elle aussi a son
avis sur la question sur ses intentions
gauche droite je pense qu'on est en
train de payer les histoires du passé
les rancoeurs et j'ai vraiment envie
qu'on tourne cette page là j'avoue que
moi j'étais pas mr dans l'est dans les
mandats précédents donc je ne juge
assistait son bien sans bien connaître
tous les conflits
je pense que maintenant il serait temps
pour chacun d'entre nous de tourner la
page pour que pour bien être des
habitants tout simplement parce que
c'est ça qui doit nous animer à
travailler pour le bien des habitants et
travailler avec toutes les communes
quelle que soit la taille de ces
différentes communes ce qui va nous
amener à parler de la verrière l'une des
plus petites ces 50 ans oui la verrière
un peu moins de 6000 habitants elle fait
partie de l'agglomération historique de
saint quentin en yvelines depuis 1972
on parlait alors à l'époque de
villenouvelle elle était jusqu'au 1er
janvier la plus petite ville de
saint-quentin aujourd'hui il est aussi
coignac 4000 habitants la verrière
coignières deux élus au sein du conseil
communautaire sur 75 on a évoqué le
sujet est-ce que c'est suffisant selon
vous à la rage ou vous craignez de ne
pas être assez représentés ces deux élus
pour votre commune et puis deux élus
pourquoi oui mais voilà ça fait 4 je
pense pas que les choses se présentent
comme ça parce que c'est pas le nombre
de représentations se font bien guînes
logique de poids proportionnel donc
c'est pas tout à fait cette question qui
va se poser c'est la question de
l'ambition du territoire vous pouvez
avoir des petites communes qui ont fini
leur développement qui sont dans la
gestion de l'existant et qui vont avoir
une position un peu différente dans
l'agglomération et puis d'autres qui ont
effectivement c'est notre cas une des
projets de développement et donc du coup
qui vont peut-être être sollicitant
auprès de l'agglomération au titre des
compétences de cette agglomération
voilà c'est pas tout à fait une question
de taille après chaque ville développe
c'est sûr pour une petite ville et pour
un maire d'une petite ville
c'est beaucoup d'énergie à déployer pour
se faire entendre ce faire commencer à
entendre quand on est mère d'une
ville c'est différent une grande ville
je pense qu'il ya ya ya ya deux choses
il ya non à peut-être je dis pas pour
les maires des plus grandes villes mais
c'est sûr qu'on a une proximité
immédiate partie des habitants de la
verrière au numéro de téléphone du merle
appelle donc on est au courant en live
un peu de tout ce qui se passe donc on a
une proximité automatique de par le
nombre moshe connais quasiment tous les
habitants dont il ya cette proximité qui
est un atout pour la gestion du mandat
la deuxième c'est gai pas de mystère il
faut prendre son bâton de pèlerin et
aller frapper à toutes les portes se
faire entendre se faire écouter
présenter expliquer peut-être encore
plus pour pas être oubliés en tout cas
d'un c'est aujourd'hui en france on
travaille beaucoup sur les des contrats
de plan d'aidé des grands schémas donc
qui balaye d'une manière un peu général
l'élégance intentions vont quand vous
êtes dans un tout petit territoire une
petite ville vous avez intérêt à un
moment donné que votre territoire sur
bois bien pointer vos enjeux bien
expliqué justement est ce qu'il ya des
enjeux particuliers sur lequel vous
serez attentif plus que sur d'autres des
métiers pour la meilleure il y en a à
mon avis deux c'est que la verrière
comme trappe et comme pour partie
plaisir en nous allons en avoir la
particularité d'être des communes
retenues en renouvellement urbain c'est
à dire que dans des dans une
agglomération qui même si elle voit ses
moyens réduits reste une agglomération
qui est plutôt plus aisé que d'autres
les inégalités territoire les inégalités
entre populations doivent être un enjeu
majeur à traiter donc la verrière fait
partie d'un de ces enjeux là et puis le
deuxième c'est que on est concerné par
l'amélioration des réseaux de transport
et le positionnement de notre
agglomération
mais nous peut-être avec la volonté que
le réseau existant sont mieux prises en
compte c'est un débat qu'on a le dessus
d'ailleurs il ya unanimité des mères
c'est bien développer les réseaux de
nouveau parce qu'il faut effectivement
désenclaver des territoires qui vont
être aménagés mais il faut aussi
évidemment soutenir les réseaux
existants parce que c'est la survie de
les emplois de du déplacement dans notre
agglomération vers les zones d'emploi
michel laugier sûr c'est sur ce
développement que sa petite commune
comme la verrière qui a un potentiel
encore à se créer à se développer
tout à fait
l'un de ses jeux mais je m'implique
pleinement auprès des maires de toutes
les communes de saint quentin et allah
le sait très bien
justement sur la représentation des
communes si on avait appliqué la loi il
n'y aurait plus qu'un seul représentant
la verrière et moi dans ma proposition
75 justement c'était que les petites
communes puissent avoir plus de
représentants que la loi donc voyez bien
la volonté qui est la mienne de vouloir
que une participation plus active des
différentes communes
il n'y a pas de petites communes de
yahia des des habitants il ya des
territoires est d'ailleurs bon au cours
de ces derniers mois ne serait ce que
sur la commune de la verrière
l'agglomération a souhaité avoir la
maîtrise complète du foncier par exemple
de la zac des bécanes alors à travers
d'autres structures comme
l'établissement public foncier des
yvelines mais donc aujourd'hui nous
avons travaillé justement à la maîtrise
de ce foncier parce que vous avoue avoir
tous les projets ce n'est pas la
maîtrise du foncier ou n'irait pas loin
mais notre notre travail au cours de ces
derniers mois avec le maire de la
verrière ces deux d'avoir cette maîtrise
du foncier
pareil sur le pôle gare de la verrière
on travaille il ya des réunions
régulières avec tous les partenaires le
stif le département la région la sncf
est en avance de manière très positive
donc voilà je veux dire c'est que ya une
implication il ya des territoires il ya
des territoires en devenir et la commune
de là derrière c'est vrai que pendant de
nombreuses années ben n'a pas n'a pas eu
ce le développement que l'on pouvait
espérer
aujourd'hui ben ça fait partie de
l'avenir du territoire de 50 ha dont
vous voyez bien c'est tous ces projets
que nous aurons à construire dans
l'ensemble des communes qu'elles soient
petites ou moins ou moyennes ou très
grande
en tout cas nous notre volonté c'est de
faire un seul territoire et surtout à
voir ce travail du collégialité est en
tous les cas moi je me suis toujours
bien impliqué de faire en sorte que le
conseil des maires est vraiment ce rôle
stratégique et ceux concédés mère
existera toujours à 12 communes et ps
est le développement de la verrière va
donc se faire sous une présidence droite
centre-droit et s'est pas fait sans une
président
de gauche ça vire en images non plus
tout le
la région change et on aura besoin de la
région comme partenaire non ça c'est les
règles du jeu politique c'est c'est
comme ça on pourra d'ailleurs
s'interroger beaucoup doit juste insisté
quand même parce que la richesse d'un
territoire ce sont ses habitants ce sont
ces salariés et on oublie quelquefois
que ces voix là c'est pas des entités
même quand on parle d'une entreprise
l'entreprise la richesse d'une
entreprise c'est quand même ses salariés
principalement et bien pour notre
territoire c'est aussi que nos habitants
soient bien appliquées
ce qui va être un vrai enjeu un vrai
défi ce n'est pas facile à 150 milles
c'est un nouveau défi à 230 milles
il va falloir effectivement qu'on trouve
les moyens que nos habitants soient
concernés par le projet de territoire
interrogés et qu'ils puissent donner
leur avis sur le développement futur
merci à tous les deux d'être venu c'est
la fin de ce set 8 politique édition
spéciale élargissement de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines proposé par les rédactions de
téléphiles et de radio sensations merci
à nos invités merci nicolas également et
à très bientôt sur nos différentes
antennes pour suivre l'actualité locale
au quotidien excellente soirée